-Guys, earlier today is usually
when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
return some e-mails,
and of course, I send out
thank-you notes.
And I was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was running a bit behind,
so I thought if you guys
wouldn't mind,
I'd just like to write out
my weekly thank-you notes
right now.
Is that cool with you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much.
James, can I get some thank-you-
note-writing music, please?
[ Somber piano music playing ]
[ Laughter ]
Always in a good mood.
-Jimmy Baseball.
-Always in a good mood. Okay.
[ Piano music stops ]
[ Piano music restarts ]
Thank you, Father's Day,
for basically being Mother's Day
without the eye contact.
[ Piano music stops,
laughter and applause ]
[ Piano music restarts ]
Thank you, group photo
of world leaders at NATO,
for looking like
an a cappella group
that lasts just eight seconds
on "America's Got Talent."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Imitates buzzer ]
[ Chuckles ]
-[ Vocalizing ]
-[ Imitates buzzer ]
[ The Roots vocalizing ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you...
-What -- What was that?
-...Novavax -- What's that?
-What was that?
-Dude, it's like out of nowhere,
you can just make
an a cappella group.
-Really?
-♪ The very first time ♪
[ The Roots vocalizing ]
[ Laughter ]
-Well, not every time.
-Not every time.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Most times.
-Yeah, yeah. Sure.
-♪ Your lips said hello ♪
♪ And I said hi ♪
-[ Vocalizes off-key ]
-I guess just one time.
[ Laughter ]
[ Piano music restarts ]
-Thank you, Novavax releasing
an effective vaccine this week,
for basically being that guy
who shows up to a party
with a six-pack at 4:00 a.m.
It's like, "Novavax!
You rock!"
[ Applause ]
♪ But I was caught up ♪
[ Laughter ]
1, 2 --
♪ But I was caught up ♪
-♪ Caught up ♪
-There you go.
♪♪
-Thank you,
Biden and Putin summit,
for looking like
all of us with our dads
10 minutes into Father's Day.
[ Laughter ]
So, uh --
Family good?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
They're great.
♪♪
Thank you, spray sunscreen,
for being the closest I'll ever
get to graffiti-ing my family.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Imitating spraying ]
[ Imitating spray can shaking ]
[ Imitating spraying ]
"Biscuit"?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's my
graffiti name, Biscuit.
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-Thank you, Brooklyn Nets,
for being the most exciting team
with the least exciting name.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right. We're the Nets!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, seashells,
for showing up
in one of two places --
a beautiful shoreline
or a bowl on your aunt's toilet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Classic.
-Classic.
-It's if you run out of paper.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not why it's there.
-That's not why?
-If you run out of paper?
No. That's not why it's there.
-You have a shell, you know?
-No, no, no.
-Are you sure?
♪♪
-Thank you, hang gliding,
for being my favorite way
to see stunning views
while dangling from
an oversized Dorito.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This is a good one.
-[ Inhales sharply ]
[ Piano music restarts ]
-Thank you, ice cream trucks,
for being the only time
where I'm like, "Kids, hurry!
Run into the street
and buy sweets
from a stranger in a van."
There you have it.
Those are my thank-you notes.